let me tell you about the results to our
david pakman.com poll asking how will
donald trump's accomplishments in his
second hundred days compared to his
first hundred days now normal caveats
here before I start getting angry
right-wing emails I am NOT representing
these results as scientific polling
results this is merely representative of
the portion of our audience that chose
to go to david pakman.com and vote in
this poll okay let's take a look at the
results how will Donald Trump's
accomplishments in his second hundred
days compared to the first hundred days
42% of our audience believes that Donald
Trump will get way less done in his
second hundred days compared to his
first hundred seventeen percent believe
that Trump will get somewhat less done
so in total nearly 60% of our audience
believes that the second hundred days of
Trump will see less accomplished than
the first hundred days that alone says a
lot because very little was accomplished
in the first hundred days 31 percent of
our audience believes that Trump will
get the same amount done in the second
hundred days as he did in the first now
if you believe he got nothing done in
the first hundred days and you believe
he will get the same done in the second
hundred days it still doesn't bode well
only 10 percent of our audience believe
that Donald Trump will get any more done
during his second hundred days than the
first uh I tend to agree with our
audience that we are not going to see
accomplishments that being said I
predict that we will see way more damage
done by Trump in the second hundred days
it's also tough to say whether or not
that he accomplished a lot in the first
hundred days because just so much of
what he did was struck down yeah like
his Muslim travel ban was struck down
like the Affordable Care Act replacement
didn't go through Congress
that's a fair point which is if Donald
Trump does his part but then because of
the law the Constitution rational people
in the House and Senate it doesn't end
up being made into law is it still an
accomplishment for Trump and if he did
his part I would argue no you're the
president a buck stops with you if
you're making promises you're already
making them in the context of the fact
that there are checks and balances and I
think if you don't get them done you
didn't get it done I think I'm undecided
on this poll but if you look at history
and
in the first 100 days is important
because that's when the president has
the most pull on Congress
yeah and that's going to fade away
normally except Trump came in with
already low approval ratings so it was
it's it's you're probably right that
it's the best window for Trump to get
things done and yet he had a quote
record high approval for his presidency
a 42 percent just pathetic
our next poll at david pakman.com is do
you believe that donald trump is
untouchable no matter what he does vote
now at david pakman.com nearly 500 of
you already have and we will have those
results for you next week